the first metric of interest is Net
Promoter Score or NPS NPS is a customer
loyalty metric that is determined by
asking users one question on a scale of
zero to ten how likely are you to
recommend this product or service to a
friend
customers who respond with a number
between zero and six are called your
detractors customers who score seven or
eight all your passives and anyone
ranking with a nine or ten as a promoter
and to actually calculate your NPS you
take the percent of promoters and then
subtract out the percent of detractors
this actually means that MPs cans fall
between negative 100 and positive 100
you could for example have everyone
value between zero and six a good Net
Promoter Score will vary by industry as
you can tell from this chart many
industries have a wide range for Net
Promoter scores and you can see their
averages in these squares along the
graph if you'd like to take a closer
look at this chart you can refer to it
in the instructor notes click-through
rate is another metric that you'll find
associated with website buttons links
and email campaigns with CTR you're
measuring whether or not a user took
action CTS are helpful for determining
how customers advance through steps of a
purchase for example one checkout flow
could be on Udacity s website we could
collect data on how many users check out
a homepage go to a description page for
a product how many click to start a free
trial and how many actually complete the
payment information form to register for
that free trial daily active users are
Diu is another common metric and it can
take on multiple meetings the trickiest
part is defining what active means for
your product it could be as simple as
logging in performing specific tasks or
making a purchase depending on your
business you can track the number of
users over time and you'll likely see
some variation from day to day maybe in
a plateau and then hopefully you'll see
an uptick where you get a lot of
adoptions from new users by relating
product launches new features press
releases and even marketing efforts to
this data you can get a sense for what
might be driving your traffic
these next three metrics are similar to
daily active
users accept you're tracking active
users in whichever way you define active
over some defined period of time so
instead of having daily active users you
might have weekly active users or
monthly active users here's a bar chart
showing monthly active users for
whatsapp whatsapp is a popular mobile
messaging application now you might be
wondering why some of these bars are
missing and it's just because the source
of the data didn't have this information
it probably better to show this as a
line chart over time but I didn't want
to give the impression that these points
were actually in the data to calculate
any X day active users
you simply total the number of unique
users who initiated sessions on your
website or mobile application from a
starting date all the way until the
ending date you might also look at
patterns over weekday or weekend
activity to spot trends for example
Twitter determine that if a user opened
Twitter seven times in one month then
the user was likely to return by
tracking active users and possibly what
features they use you might determine
what is driving users back to the
product and finally another useful
metric is retention it's the opposite of
churn or attrition retention describes
the number or the percent of users you
keep over a certain period of time well
not counting any new users you acquired
during that same time interval now this
example wouldn't really be that great
because I'm only keeping let's say about
1% of my users after 12 weeks even
better you can monitor cohorts of users
based on when they start using the
product or service for example you can
create retention curves for two groups
of users let's say one group of users
starts on January 1st while the other
starts on January 8th to learn more
about cohort analysis check out this
article on y'all's blog which is linked
in the instructor notes the article
discusses how to measure retention and
use cohort analysis while looking at
user retention for Pinterest and Twitter
now these are some of the common
baseline metrics and whatever metrics
you choose the metric needs to signal
that users are using the product in an
expected way and that those same users
are likely to come back and use the
product more this certain
every metric that you might want but
these are some common ones that you'll
use in most products in the next video
we'll look at a framework for how you
can come up with other metrics